Hello,
and welcome
to the Rawkode Academy. I'm your host, David
Flanagan, also known as Rawkode across the internet.
Today is an episode of Rawkode Live where
we get hands on with some sort of
cloud native or cloud native adjacent technology.
And today, we're taking a look at how
to improve
your build times for Docker images.
To join us and guide us today on
our session, I'm very excited to introduce Michael
Irwin from the Docker DevRel team. Hey, man.
How's it going?
Doing well. It's good to be here with
you today.
Awesome. Yeah. I'm really excited. It's always good
to and you can take, like, a real
problem that pretty much every team has and
then give them some insights and solutions on
how to make that problem disappear, which I'm
I'm hoping will be the outcome of today's
session.
Absolutely.
Could you just take a minute or two
and, you know, introduce you if anyone has
got familiar with you and your work?
Absolutely. So as you mentioned, my name is
Michael Irwin, and I'm part of the
developer relations team here at Docker.
I've been with Docker working
full time for about two years,
but even prior to that, was actually one
of the the Docker captains for five years.
I've been in the container space for quite
a long time, and it's been fun to
watch it grow and go through all of
its
bumps and evolutions and changes and and and
just
the this entire ecosystem over the last, you
know, seven years, at least that I've been
a part of it.
I also teach a a class. I've developed
courses at
I teach at Virginia Tech, so courses on
containers and Kubernetes as well too, so I
I do a lot of teaching
those that are brand new to the space
as well too, and it's a ton of
fun to kinda work with industry experts, but
then also those that are just getting into
the space as well too. And there's obviously
a huge
chasm between them at times too, and it's
figuring out how do how do we better
connect people, but it's a it's a ton
of fun. So but, yeah, I'm I'm excited
to be here today and talk about our
our newest product, Build Cloud.
Awesome.
Well, we're definitely gonna talk about Build Cloud
and get hands on with the demo. But,
you know, maybe we
impromptu question that you had no idea it
was coming. Right? But, you know, Docker's actually
released an awful lot over the last three,
six, and nine months. Do you wanna just
give us a TLDR of anything that's top
of mind that you think is interesting and
you wanna share with people?
Yeah. Absolutely. And so as you mentioned, you
know, Docker has been doing a lot. I
think most people still think of Docker as
mostly Docker desktop or even just the Docker
engine and just the ability to run containers,
build images, etcetera.
But over the last yeah. As you said,
over the last year, we've been trying to
expand the the portfolio and adding more products
and more services. So the the first new
product that we released, and we announced it
going generally available back in in DockerCon in
October, was a new product called Docker Scout
that really focuses on building a secure software
supply chain and analyzing
your images,
making sure they they meet organizational policies,
and and it's it's actually pretty solid, pretty
awesome to to work with as well too.
So, you know, a lot of people think
of, like, image vulnerabilities, and that's just one
element, but also,
are you building on trusted and approved base
images for your organization?
Do you have open source license issues that
you need to worry about? Maybe your organization
has the policies of, you know, our images
by default shouldn't be running as the root
user, and so, you know, are your images
meeting those policies? So
lots of really cool stuff there. And then,
yeah, Build Cloud is our our newest product.
But between all those, there's been lots of
other new features and capabilities, Docker Debug.
There's been
Docker Net
Panda. Yep. Yep. To help bootstrap new projects,
compose watch. I mean, there's just been a
lot of Web essentially. My favorite. My favorite.
The whole Wagons stuff. Yeah. Absolutely.
So yeah. And, I mean, it may be
hard to keep up with at all.
I mean, I'm trying my best to keep
up, but, you know, Docker has definitely embraced,
I don't know, tooling and experience, developer experience.
And they really seem to be tackling really
a lot of those challenging problems that people
experience,
whether they're new to container tech or whether
they're experienced. Right? There's a lot of frustrations
and it's nice to see Docker tackle them
head on. Even, you know, the the failment
and stuff for people that are running Mac
like like me.
For dynamic interpreted languages, that has been a
pain.
And I was really shocked when I used
a large PHP application and the performance is
night and day from where it was Oh,
yeah. Twelve
months ago or or two years ago. So
yeah. Awesome stuff.
Yep.
But we're not here to talk about all
of that other awesome stuff. We're here to
talk about Docker Build Cloud. And let's start
with a a bit of context or a
problem that I think everybody's probably had at
some point in their container latest. Right?
And that even s k c d has
a meme that's often swapped out from it's
compiling and we're running about our chairs sword
fighting. And I see all the time with
my Docker images building
because these things can be can be slow
and there's a lot of foot guns,
which I'm not saying Docker Build Cloud has
got effects, but there are a lot of
foot guns for people that are new to
containers that don't understand how layer caching works
and then cache invalidation and all this stuff.
But use Docker in it and it's gonna
help you avoid some of them things. But
Docker build cloud can give us some dramatic
performance numbers. Your blog post that I was
looking at prior to this episode says it
could speed up a build by up to
39%.
That is not a trivial number or performance
and benefit. So do you wanna give us
a bit more details on what Build Cloud
is Yeah. And why people should pay attention?
Yeah. Absolutely. And and I'll even I'll just
do one small correction. The the blog post,
so it wasn't 39%. It was even 39
times.
So there's
Of of course, you know, numbers can be,
you know, a little hand wavy at times,
but we have seen pretty significant improvements with
with the build speeds.
And so, yeah, a a couple things that
you mentioned there. So when when I'm building
a a container image, there's there's a lot
that goes into that. And especially if I'm
building on my local machine,
if it's the first time I've done that
build, I'm having to do the build from
scratch. And we're we're looking at those builds,
you know, there's lots of dependencies and compilation
or, you know, just depending on what language
and what tools you're using.
You know, if we look at the layers,
my source code may be layers seven and
eight, but I still have to build, you
know, layers one through six
at least to populate my cache and and
get things in a good place.
And, you know, if then we look across
an entire team of developers. If there's 10
developers on a team, well, then that means
all of those,
you know, initial layers are having to be
rebuilt across the entire team. It's like, at
the end of the day, there's a lot
of this layer caching and whatnot. Like, how
can we make it so that one person
can build once and then everybody can benefit
from that shared cache environment? So that that's
kinda one aspect of of Build Cloud is
this, by having the shared runner,
one person can or even a CI pipeline
can populate the cache, and then everybody else
can benefit from it.
Another thing that we heard quite often was,
you know, for larger projects,
compilation may just take a long time. Either
there's lots to compile
or, you know, if I'm on a team
that's looking at multi architecture, for example, and
now we're having to do AMD sixty four
and ARM sixty four, but, you know, maybe
I'm on Apple silicon, so I'm having to
emulate one or the other.
Maybe it's a Rust project, and it's just
slow. Yeah.
Exactly. And, you know, so there's just times
in which, like, can I just attach
beefier machines to my builds?
And and and so kind of internally, we
call it remote where it's kind of remote,
but it kinda feels local.
And so in many ways, that's what Build
Cloud's trying to do, like, give that remote
experience to, like, just enhance the the local
experience with remote capabilities and remote
horsepower,
but then, you know, everything still
works as you would expect it to locally.
Okay.
So would it be fair to summarize
all of those amazing features you're just gonna
cover to is like just Docker Build Cloud
is a remote build kit, build service for
anyone building container images. And the fact that
there's remote means that you can do really
cool things with the caching. That's kinda what
I'm taking away from this. Yeah. Absolutely. And
so, yeah, the the remote
yep. Shared caches,
native multi architecture,
and hopefully, as as you see there, hopefully,
it's the 39 x speed improvements that you
get. That
native multi architecture.
Yeah. And maybe that comes out in the
demo. Right? But I'm gonna I'm curious.
When I do Docker builds and I'm using
Docker build cloud, is that understanding that there's
multiple jobs that need to be run and
literally scheduling them on different machines with the
architecture native without any emulation whatsoever?
That's exactly what's happening. So, yeah, when I
do the build,
basically, it's handing off to the a a
build kit endpoint that then is basically saying,
alright. What
builder behind the scenes actually needs to take
care of this for me? And, yeah, delegates
the works to either AMD sixty four or
ARM sixty four, and there may be a
few
architectures that support or, you know, machines that
support other architectures as they come out. But,
yep, everything runs natively.
Nice. We got a not a question, but
a comment from Russell on the chat. So
he's got a project. It takes thirty minutes
to build, and the presses sound greatly.
Yeah. I mean, when I used to work
in an office, I loved those comp completion
times or build times because that meant you
can go get a coffee, you would chat
to people, but now they're all sitting at
home. I think they're just sat watching them,
and and maybe that's just me. Or I
I think maybe I'll squeeze on an episode
of, you know, the office or whatever.
Well and and, yeah, that's one of things
that, like, I'll admit as a developer at
times, it's like, enjoy those those downtimes, and,
yeah, I can pull up YouTube for a
little bit or, you know, whatever else it
might be.
And so, like, on one hand, I'm like,
okay. Great. This means I have to work
more. Is this actually what I want to
do? But at the end of the day,
like, that's that's where I love actually spending
my time building applications, solving problems, etcetera. So
in in many ways, it's like, how can
we keep you in that flow more?
Because, yeah, then it takes more time to
get back in, you know, all of the
context switching is just fine. You're framing us
too nicely. I think we need to change
the flow. Well, actually, you're taking away developers'
coffee breaks and their Netflix. Why do you
hate developers?
Yeah. When you put it that way, gosh.
Alright. Awesome. If you do have any questions,
people are watching us, please feel free to
leave them in the comment section on LinkedIn,
on x, or on YouTube. We will do
our best to tackle them as we go
today.
Alright. So I mean, you've already sold me
on this. I want this native compilation across
different architectures. I want it to be faster
and I wanna build cache that works across
multiple machines.
I very
much take advantage of working at home to
the point where yes, I'm in my office
now for a stream and I do some
work here.
But I've got kids. I'm at dance class
and I when my daughter's there, I get
my laptop out and I start working on
that.
Not having my build cash there is really
painful when I'm on a four g or
five g connection and I'm struggling to build
on the bait, so I need to or
whatever. So I want this to be better
for me well. And I think with that,
we should dive into your screen share and
start to take a look at how people
can take advantage of this
this cash flow awesomeness.
Let's do it.
So was trying to think about the opposite
of snake oil there was, and I couldn't
think. I was like, what is it? It's
like just a awesome product. So
Yep. Alright. Here. Let me
screen share, and we'll go
get this window.
Alright.
Alright. We see the Docker
Yeah. Homepage or the Build Cloud homepage at
least. That's right. So I just wanna start
here. You know, it's it's a good place
for anybody else that's kinda just getting started
with with the Build Cloud. And and so,
yeah, there's lots of the the same things
that we talked about are are scattered throughout
this page as well too. One of the
things I will call out, and this is
kind of a a a fun little thing
there, there's this savings calculator, which
you can kinda say, you know, how large
is your team and salary and how much
time spent, and you can save this much
or whatever. And, of course, you know, there's
a lot of wiggle room in here and
whatnot too, but it's it's kind of a
fun thing to just play with there.
And there's some little fun demos here of
kind of a local build versus build cloud.
And, actually, you were just talking about, you
know, taking your your laptop to dance class
and whatnot.
Let's see. It was actually back in October.
I was flying to San Francisco for GitHub
Universe,
and I was working on a a React
app or whatnot, and I was like, man,
just downloading all the the YARN dependencies and
everything while on a plane Yep. Haven't helped
me kind of thing. Like, it's gonna take
forever on that Wi Fi. But I was
like, you know, let me switch to Build
Cloud and did my build and everything. And
so all of the the build actually happened
in the cloud, and then it's just downloading
you know, instead of making thousands of connections
to download everything, it's just, you know, those
couple image layers, and the build was significantly
faster. So it was kinda fun to say
I'm doing a build
using Build Cloud while literally in the clouds
and and everything, and it and it worked
out really well. It was pretty cool.
So with that, I'll jump over. So Build
Cloud has its own web UI,
and when I jump in here,
the the first time I come in, it'll
walk me through building a builder, and that
just takes three to four minutes just to
spin up all the infrastructure and everything. But
once that's in place,
you're basically given this screen that says, hey,
here's here's how to configure everything.
All you have to do is do a
Docker login, and then you basically set up
a what's called a Buildx builder.
And if you've never used Buildx, Buildx is
a
kind of the latest, greatest build engine
and
provides a lot of really cool capabilities. We
can talk about that later, but
basically what we're doing is we're just creating
another builder here. And you'll notice that the
difference here is that we're specifying a driver
of cloud. Now this is one of the
the new things that we've we've brought to
to Buildx here.
And I just give it a name, and
then from there, it sets up all the
other magic
behind the scenes. It connects to the endpoint.
And then from there,
I can either, when I specify a build,
say I wanna use that particular builder,
or I can just say, hey, just use
that builder by default, and so build x
use sets as the default
and goes from there. And then so all
my builds, all my other, you know, even
if I just do Docker Compose up, which
we'll we'll do here in just a second,
I can see all that. Now one of
the other things that we did here,
because, you know, a lot of us are
probably very comfortable in the CLI,
but not everybody is.
I can jump in the Docker desktop as
well,
and there's this new builds tab that shows
up on the the left hand side.
And and here I can see lots of
detailed output. I've got a filter on just
for my failed builds right now. Let me
put that back. And so I can see
my build history,
and I can go up into builder settings,
and I can see all those different builders,
and I can basically just click connect to
builder
and then, you know, use this as my
default builder. So I can do everything through
the GUI. Under the hood, it's basically just
running those same commands that the build execs
create, but if I'm more GUI oriented,
that's an option for me here as well
too.
And so with that in place,
then really, I can just jump into a
project,
and I'm gonna switch over to Versus Code
here. And
I've got just a a really simple React
app. Nothing too crazy.
There's a Docker file that does multistage build.
It'll, you know, build my my React app
and and
take the compiled assets,
transpiled, whatever you wanna call it, the the
the final assets and put it into NGINX
container.
But I also have another stage here that
I can use for development,
and in Compose,
that's what I've got here, that it's gonna
use that that particular stage. So even though
I've got this other
other builder here, what's pretty cool about this
is if I and I'll even show that
there's no smoke and mirrors here. If I
do an image l s, you see I
had no images locally on my machine, so
there's no pre built caches or anything already
on my machine here.
But if I just do Docker Compose up,
it's gonna say, well, hey, I need to
build this particular image here, and you'll see
that it's using my
my DevRel builder here,
and within just a couple seconds, you know,
downloaded all the layers that were needed, and
now I've got my application up and running.
K? And I didn't have anything already downloaded,
and it was, you know, spun up pretty
quickly. Now I can start my development right
away.
And so what's cool about this, again, is
I don't have to change any of the
commands that I'm using. I don't have to
add additional arguments. I just simply run Docker
Compose up,
and the Compose will use whatever the configured
Buildx builder is, and since I've set my
Cloud Builder as the default,
it'll use that. And and what's also cool
about this then too is that, again, if
I'm in an environment where, hey, maybe I
don't have good internet connectivity right now, and
I don't want to use it, and I
just wanna stay local,
then I can just switch my builder back
to my local builder and continue on my
way. So again, I've got the choice of
do I want to use remote, do I
want to use local, and I can pick
and choose between
each of them
based on what my current needs are. And
I don't have to change any of my
commands, I just change my configuration.
So maybe I'll pause there for a second.
Any questions coming up yet?
Oh, I think you're muted.
Or maybe I could maybe I just can't
hear you.
The fun of livestreams. Yeah.
This one, do a little song and dance.
Right?
Not hearing anything yet.
Okay. Yeah. Go for it.
So maybe while he's doing that, I'll I'll
just continue
chatting through some of the demo whatnot. And
so maybe if you throw the screen share
back up, then we'll
here we go. So so, yeah, I can
do a compose up here.
A normal build first. And, also, I'll just
call this sample React app with the final
dot to do my build here. And, again,
we'll see that this is going to use
the that cloud builder. And since I built
this earlier, k, on the the remote,
again, using this remote environment, all of build
layers are cached here.
And so even though I didn't have the
image locally, I haven't built it locally, anything
of that sort, since it's a shared cache
environment,
I can leverage that cache even though, again,
I'd had nothing
on my local machine. And what's cool about
this then is that if I pass this
off to a teammate and they clone this
repo and do the build, they're gonna get
the same cache, and it's gonna build immediately
as
Now if I go in here and I
change some of this to, you know, hey,
let's make this more exciting, add some more
exclamation points,
and then
do another build, in this case, obviously, that's
gonna
the cache is gonna be a miss here,
and we'll actually see the the build. I'll
download those layer, the the new layers, and
good to go here. So, again, by having
this remote environment,
any any member of my team that's building
with this is helping populate a cache that
then the rest of us can all leverage,
making our builds theoretically faster.
I'm still not hearing you.
Weird.
Now I'm wondering if it's
or maybe if a
viewer is watching, maybe
confirm if if it's just me or not.
I guess I can pull up the stream
too.
That's why I do a little song and
dance.
Okay.
Can't hear either.
Okay. I at least pulled up the stream
from a couple minutes ago and
confirmed.
Okay. Yeah.
We finally silence. Hey. Hey. Getting getting
some
fun comments coming into chat.
Strange. Yeah. I still can't hear you.
I'm just gonna have fun with chat here.
So
our host is muted here.
Interesting.
Okay. Sounds good.